[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Yannick jade bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sénateur écologiste de
Paris ancien candidat à la
présidentielle et ancien député européen
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale bonjour Julien lescill
bonjour Orian manchini bonjour monsieur
jade de la voie du Nord on va évidemment
commencer en parlant de ce déplacement
d'Emmanuel Macron 2 jours il était en
Israël en sixisjordanie en Jordanie en
Égypte pour relancer le processus de
paix est-ce qu'il vous a
convaincu on s'est interrogé toutes et
tous pour savoir pourquoi il avait
décalé par rapport à beaucoup de chefs
d'État et de gouvernement sa visite en
Israël pour dire notre solidarité euh
avec le peuple palestinien après les
attentats barbares horribles du
Hamas la réalité c'est que je pense que
ce décalage lui a permis d'aller à la
ramala et que c'était une bonne chose à
la fois dire combien nous étions auprès
des Israéliens auprès des familles en
deuillé des familles évidemment dans la
dans l'attente terrible parce que il y a
les otages mais de réaffirmer à ramala
que la France
portait toujours une solution à deux
état et que son expression quand il a
dit un
mort
français un mort israélien et un mort
palestinien avait la même valeur j'ai
trouvé que c'était une parole forte et
c'était une parole utile en revanche
personne n'a rien compris à sa coalition
antiamas j'allais vous poser la question
et là ça a été je trouve que c'est une
ça a totalement parasité sa visite
visiblement c'est en parti improvisé ça
n'est pas calé avec le qu d'orsé
lui-même a rétropédalé toute la journée
pour essayer d'expliquer
qu'évidemment à la différence de la
coalition antidaesh on nallait pas
envoyer des soldats pour combattre dans
la bande de Gaza donc il y a eu là une
improvisation dramatique qui a porté
fortement préjudice au message important
qu'il est venu rappeler 1 notre
solidarité avec les le peuple israélien
de Israël ne doit pas punir les
population civile palestinienne dans la
bande de Gaza intervenir militairement
serait une erreur donc tout ça c'était
positif mais parasité par cette annonce
que personne n'a compris et va-t-il
suffisamment loin selon vous dans l'aide
à porté au Palestiniens il a annoncé
l'envoi par la France d'un navire
hôpital de la Marine nationale d'un
avion chargé d'aide et de médicamenten
mais est-ce que pour vous c'est
suffisant écoutez ça va dans la bonne
direction ça souligne à la
fois l'horreur que vivent aujourd'hui
les Palestiniens dans la bande de
gazins tous les voyants sont au rouge
probablement aujourd'hui on aura 2 tiers
des hôpitaux dans la bande de Gaza qui
ne pourront plus fonctionner on a déjà
plus de des quasiment les 2 tiers des
centres médicaux qui ne peuvent plus
fonctionner donc on a une une population
qui est dans une prison à ciel ouvert
depuis 30 ans et là d'un seul coup qui
vit des bombardements incessants qui
évidemment sont des crimes de guerre une
démocratie ne peut pas affamer
assoifffer bombarder des des populations
civiles dans un territoire bloqué donc
le message de la France il est clair
maintenant il faut que l'Union
européenne pèse beaucoup plus pour
éviter la catastrophe elle pèse pas
assez pour vous non c'est alors oursola
van derl a été pathétique en tant que
présidente de la Commission européenne
elle a été complètement à côté de la
plaque je parce que si vous voulez la
façon dont elle a considéré ce qui était
d'ailleurs un peu les premiers mots de
la France après les attentats terroriste
du Hamas qui était de dire au fond on
est au côté du peuple palestinien très
bien nous sommes au côté du peuple
palestinien mais en justifiant toute
mesure de représaille du gouvernement
israélien qui était évidemment la limite
à ne pas franchir Madame Van der qui
pendant son mandat a donné un visage à
la Commission européenne sur l'Ukraine a
plutôt fait un sans faute là pour le
coup à mon avis par y compris par depuis
quelques mois son
atlantisme un peu un peu B front c'est
par calcul politique selon vous on dit
par exemple qu'elle a voulu donner des
des gages à à à la droite écoutez oui
elle donne des gages à la droite vous
savez
euh il va y avoir les élections
européennes euh son mandat fut
dépend des élections européennes elle
est la présidente de la commission issue
de la droite européenne alors elle a
plutôt parfois jouer plutôt
intelligemment sur sur le Green Deal
mais là elle est en train de se
réaligner avec la droite européenne avec
la droite allemande qui est aujourd'hui
une droite qui est plus attirée par
l'extrême droite que par la prise de
responsabilité en responsabilité
en lucidité donc sur cette
sitationéibilisé l'Union européenne pour
vous en tout cas elle a participé à ce
que ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui le sud
global considère que l'Occident
aujourd'hui est en permanence dans le de
poids de mesure que au fond évidemment
encore une fois comment ne pas être au
côté du peuple israélien après des
attentats d'une barbarie sans nom mais
mais il nous faut y compris parce que
israël est une démocratie moi je dénonce
le gouvernement d'extrême droite
israélien mais il a été élu par les
urnes c'est une démocratie et quand on
est une démocratie on peut pas
s'affranchir du droit international donc
l'Union européenne il y a un enjeu de de
temporalité dans cette crise
abominable tout ne peut pas être fait
maintenant parce qu'il y a tellement de
de ressentiments de douleur de haine
aujourd'hui que il faut pas griller les
étapes mais par exemple l'Union
européenne qui défend la solution à deux
états
doit prévoir la reconnaissance de l'État
de Palestine aujourd'hui on doit prévoir
la reconnaissance de l'État de Palestine
pour inscrire on sait à quel point ça va
être difficile encore cette semaine 90
morts euh Palestiniens par les colons ou
l'armée israélienne en Jordanie tout ça
est insupportable on sait la difficulté
de la solution à deux États mais il y en
a pas de meilleur aujourd'hui mais vous
dites que c'est pas le temps vous dites
tout ne peut pas être fait aujourd'hui
vous dites c'est pas le temps du
processus de paix aujourd'hui il faut le
prévoir là le temps c'est le cesser le
feu l'arrêt immédiat des bombardements
des populations civiles de Gaza tout
faire pour empêcher que l'armée
israélienne entre dans Gaza avec on le
sait tous les dommages collatéraux et
les centaines peut-être encore des
milliers d'enfants qui vont être tués
des
soldat les termes sont les termes sont
importants parce que vous vous parlez de
cesser le feu le président de la de la
République lui il parle de trêve
humanitaire pour vous c'est c'est pas ça
va pas suffisamment loin ce qu'il faut
c'est l'arrêt des bombardements le débat
sur le ccfeu au fond il est
sur la
légitime le légitime combat contre le
terrorisme terrorisme bien ça
aujourd'hui c'est ça donc au fond moi
quand je parle d'un cesser le feu c'est
pas d'arrêter de combattre le terrorisme
il faut y compris par des coopérations
de renseignement c'est une
responsabilité particulièrement des
démocraties qui sont les plus attaqués
par les terroristes ou qui sont
largement attaqués par les terroristes
donc on a une
responsabilité de de de combattre le
terrorisme mais on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui ce combat contre le
terrorisme de la part de Benjamin
netaniaahou c'est les bombardements des
populations civiles à Gaza donc il faut
que ces bombardements cesse il faut que
l'horreur cesse à Gaza que la crise
humanitaire cesse à Gaza et que
effectivement il y ait d'autres moyens
de combattre le terrorisme et c'est
certainement pas en bombardant euh avec
des des des centaines d'enfants de
femmes et d'hommes qui meurent presque
chaque jour qu'on va réussir mais
l'armée israélienne juste elle a annoncé
cette avoir mené des opérations ciblées
dans la bande de Gaza avec des
tanksz ça on nen sait rien enfin moi je
vous je suis pas un expert militaire euh
évidemment ces opérationsl on connaît
pas exactement comment elles se
déroulent qui elle vise donc j'ai pas
d'avis sur comment ça se passe ce que je
sais aujourd'hui c'est que des enfants
des adultes sont en train de mourir
faute de soins euh on a une une une une
bande qui est affamée assoifffée sans
électricité des conditions de vie des
conditions sanitaire absolument terrible
et que rien de tout ça n'est justifiable
aujourd'hui avez-vous eu la crainte de
de de voir Orter sur le sol national ce
ce conflit euh le président Herzog le
président israélien euh disait sa peur
pour la communauté juive en France
écoutez on a une multiplication
effroyable des actes terroristes des
actes antisémites pardon euh euh euh on
le voit sur les réseaux sociaux on le
voit euh euh la parole se libère de
manière pathétique affligeante donc
évidemment il y a un risque et moi je
veux dire toute la solidarité des des
écologies vis-à-vis euh de la communauté
juif française il est terrible que la
communauté juive aujourd'hui soit
victime de l'importation euh d'un
conflit euh dont ils n'ont évidemment
aucune responsabilité et donc on a là
encore une fois à à se donner tous les
moyens de lutter contre
l'antisémitisme l'antisémitisme faut le
rappeler toujours ça n'est pas une
opinion c'est un délit mais est-ce qu'on
se les donne suffisamment juste les
moyens est-ce que le gouvernement on
fait assez là écoutez euh est-ce qu'on
se donne les moyens c'est toujours
compliqué aujourd'hui euh euh euh de on
sait à quel point farosse parfois manque
de moyens qui est la pl on a des menaces
on on a des menaces terroristes on a la
multiplication sur les réseaux sociaux
encore une fois des propos antisémite et
donc il faut toujours plus de moyens
pour traiter ça et puis surtout punir
encore une fois quand c'est un délit on
punit est-ce que la classe politique est
aussi à la hauteur des des enjeux est-ce
que vous pensez que certains enflamment
le dossier plus qu'il ne la pèse
oui on peut le dire je pense que dans ce
moment de de de de drame
absolu il nous faut avoir à la fois des
paroles de
fermeté dans la condamnation du
terrorisme il nous faut des paroles de
responsabilité dans le respect du droit
international on l'a dit
sur notamment les les de pas d'éviter
que les populations civiles Gazaoui et
Mayon et d'ailleurs maintenant si
Jordanie soit euh puni pour les actes
abominables du Hamas euh et il faut euh
oui il faut être à la hauteur de
l'événement et moi quand je vois la
multiplication des polémiques utilisant
un mot utilisant une visite utilisant un
truc
Jech je trouve que c'est euh c'est
affligeant par mélchon qui a accusé yel
brun pité de camper à tel av viive
écoutez euh tout ça euh euh euh les
accusations
à l'Assemblée nationale et j'ai
trouvé que le le le la le débat qui a eu
au Sénat était d'une
auteur bourlange a été très très Bonal
chtien Chatelin aussi pour les pour les
écologistes donc il a il y a des prises
d'auteur mais vous rendez compte le
traumatisme pour les Français comme pour
beaucoup de citoyens dans le monde sur
ce qui passe et donc il nous faut à la
fois donner de la
perspective
expliquer pourquoi tout ça arrive donner
encore une fois sur CEET del Mélenchon
Yanni jade parce queil y a brun pivé qui
reçoit des menaces de mort antisémite
dit que Jean-Luc Mélenchon lui a mis une
CBE dans le dos qu'est-ce que vous avez
pensé de ce tweet écoutez
moi écoutez j'ai j'ai j'ai pas de j'ai
pas de souci à dire que trop souvent
Jean-Luc Mélenchon euh attise les
braises plutôt que de participer à ce
que les feux s'éteignent euh et
donc je je je pense que cette façon en
permanence de durcir
euh de de jouer de la polémique de
l'invective ne participe pas à apaiser
notre pays dans une situation dramatique
encore une fois ce qu'on
vit évidemment maintenant au prochorient
ce qu'on vit avec l'Ukraine et la Russie
ce qu'on vit avec l'Arménie lekarabach
l'Azerbaïdjan ce qu'on vit en Afrique du
Nord ce qu'on vit au Soudan tout ça est
terrible vous imaginez que les
Françaises et les Français sont percutés
tous les soirs par des images
dramatiques et vous rajoutez les chocs
climatiques et vous rajoutez les
injustices sociales et si la réponse de
la classe politique ce sont les
polémiques et les invectives dans le
débat politique les Françaises et les
Français est- qu'il faut une réponse
ferme parce qu'avant même ce tweet vous
demandiez vous à la gauche de suspendre
ses relations avec la France insoumise
dès leurs propos refusant de qualifier
le Hamas de terroriste le PS l'a fait a
suspendu ses relations votre parti ne
l'a pas fait clairement est-ce que c'est
une faute non c'est pas une faute moi si
vous voulez je suis très clair
l'anupes été une stratégie intelligente
en mai 2022 quand il a fallu au fond
essayer d'avoir le maximum de députés à
l'Assemblée nationale cette union parce
que nous n'avons pas la proportionn à
l'Assemblée nationale ce qui est une
catastrophe démocratique cette union a
permis peut-être d'avoir deux fois plus
de députés que si on avait pas fait
l'union on sait que au fond le projet de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon était de faire de
l'anupès les insoumis en grand HM donc
avec une méthode de gouvernance voilà
extrêmement verticale et au fond on se
soumettait et au projet et à la méthode
de gouvernance de Jean-Luc Mélenchon à
partir du moment où nous avons
revendiqué notre diversité nos cultures
politiques nos avis différents tout a
commencé à déraper donc pour ma part je
l'ai dit je pense que la nupè dans ce
format là est morte elle ne peut pas
être l'espoir de la gauche et des
écologistes pour 2027 je pense que les
relations au sein de l'anupes y compris
entre les dirigeants et franchement je
je je félicite marine Tondelier pour
garder en permanence son calme mais ces
relations sont délétaires ça ne peut
plus d dors pourquoi pourquoi rester
dans l'intergroupe pourquoi continuer à
mener des actions communes dès lors
qu'on sait qu'on le fait avec des
acteurs qui ne ne souhait pas une une
réunion ce que dis ce que je ce que je
pense c'est que euh et on l'a vu à la
présidentielle de 2022 et je l'ai vu à
mon détriment il y a pas d'électorat
irréconciliable il peut y avoir des
postures politiques qui pour ma part
sont disqualifiantes quand on ne dénonce
pas le Hamas comme organisation
terroriste j'entends mais vous restez
dans un statut quo chez les écologistes
qui qui en fait ne fait pas comprendre
comment Ren plus de réunions en ce
moment il y a plus de réunions de
l'anupes vous le
savez vé avec eux oui mais ça veut pas
dire que si demain on vote ensemble que
enfant va vous êtes moins clair vous
êtes moins clair que les socialistes les
socialistes si ça
lacologistes semblent entretenir un
corps malade pourquoi ne pas acter son
décès bah écoutez un l'anups ça a été
construit et aujourd'hui au fond c'est
réduit à l'Assemblée nationale donc je
laisse à mes collègues écologistes à
l'Assemblée nationale la responsabilité
de leur relation c'est et vous savez que
Cyriel châelin et le groupe écologiste a
proposé de mettre tout sur la table dans
un dans un en réunissant tous les
députés moi je pense que politiquement
si nous voulons redonner de la hauteur à
la politique si nous voulons avoir une
alternative et l'alternance en 2027 il
nous faut l'union de la gauche et des
écologistes parce que les laissez-moi
finir parce que les électorats ne sont
pas irréconciliables parce que je ne
pense pas que l'électorat insoumis
considè que le Hamas est l'Armée de
résistance de la
PAL on REP du peuple de gauche et de
l'écologie puisque par le haut ça ne
fonctionne plus vous avez des
intellectuels des fondations des singang
des syndicats des organisations de la
société civile le milieu culturel en
plus des partis politiques doivent
travailler à ce projet pour 2027 donc
jeanluc Mélenchon c'est ce que vous
demandez écoutez moi vous allez vous
allez pas me faire dire que je pense que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon serait un bon
candidat pour la gauche et pour
l'écologie parce que je pense que
peut-être que y compris ça peut passer
au second tour peut-être que la nupes
alors je sais pas on est quand même
aujourd'hui dans des dans des tensions
qui sont extrêmement lourdes sur ce que
je pense être des valeurs fondamentales
mais c'est la direction insoumise qui
est comme ça mais de toute façon ça peut
pas gagner au second tour je veux dire
ça sera un crash face à Marine Le Pen ce
qui serait le pire pour le pays ce qui
serait le pire pour la gauche et
l'écologie donc je pense qu'il faut
retravailler le
projet pour partir avec le peuple de
gauche quand la gauche a gagné c'est que
généralement il y a un mouvement dans la
société qui associe les partis
politiques mais qui ne se résume pas au
partis politiques donc il faut repartir
de ce peuple là mettons autour d'une
table encore une fois les intellectuels
les milieux de la culture les
organisations de la société civile les
syndicats dans mais ça c'est très clair
c'est sur comment on fonctionne
maintenant parce que la semaine dernière
vous vous étiez très clair vous mettiez
ça sur le terrain des valeurs vous
disiez pour des questions de valeur il
faut suspendre nos relations est-ce que
vous êtes déçu que les écologistes ne
l'ai pas fait moi je considère encore
une fois que Marine Tondelier a été
extrêmement clairire sur la question des
valeurs Cyriel châelin aussi en tant que
présidente du groupe écologiste ils ont
à gérer des habitudes de travail et puis
vous savez qu'en plus le groupe insoumis
à l'Assemblée nationale n'est pas
homogène vous avez certains députés qui
ont clairement marquer leur distance par
rapport à la direction insoumise donc on
va pas disqualifier herufin etottin et
les autres alors qu'ils ont été très
clairs sur la question des valeurs donc
aujourd'hui en fait moi on na pas
assumé
l'affaissement politique de la direction
des insoumis c'est à eux de clarifier
leur position s'ils veulent que leur
socle de valeur s'ils veulent qu'il y
ait de nouveau un travail entre partis
politiques mais est-ce que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il fait ça pour saperer la
gauche selon vous écoutez j'en sais
rien et est-ce que Luche à expos tout le
reste de l'interview là-dessus parce que
c'est au fond c'est c'est même pas la
hauteur de ce qui se passe je pense que
au fond Jean-Luc Mélenchon créups avec
le résultat qu'il avait fait à la
présidentielle se mettait au cœur de la
reconstruction de l'animation de la
gauche et de l'écologie je veux dire il
a perdu ce statut parce qu'au fond en
interne il a purgé et il purge la la la
la nupesse parce qu'au fond parfois ils
l'ont exprimé de manière dramatique en
disant finalement soyez soumis sinon
vous êtes des collabos quand ils ont
quand ils ont comparé Rousell à Dorio
vous pensez qu'il est de ceux qui veut
finalement tuer le sa création bien sûr
bien sûr parce qu'à partir du moment où
on on revend notre diversité on
revendique nos différences c'est pour
lui insupportable donc au fond voilà
c'est une c'est une branche du
lambertisme c'est la purge stalinienne
vous la qualifiez comme vous voulez
c'est un peu compliqué de mettre les
lambertistes et les staliniens dans la
même dans la même dans le même dans la
même pièce mais au fond c'est en tout
cas ce sont des méthodes et sont des des
des des des positions politiques marqué
par l'antiaméricanisme primaire marqué
par la volont encore une fois qu'il n'y
ait jamais de démocratie jamais de
diversité c'est pas notre logiciel
politique donc faisons vivre l'écologie
déjà aux européennes deux autres sujets
juste pour terminer un mot sur la loi
immigration puisque le gouvernement
semble prêt à à retirer l'article 3 sur
la régularisation les titres de séjour
pour les travailleurs dans les métiers
en tension ils sont prêt à la retirer du
texte et à passer par une circulaire
comment vous le savez vous parce que
franchement là alors je je
je je suisux de vous parler an
comprendre quelle est la position du
Gouvernement sur ce C rien est tacté
mais il y a des volontés de trouver un
compromis avec les républicains en tout
cas la majorité
sénatoriale de lâcher totalement RBL sur
leur délire et donc de passer par une
circulaire qu'est-ce que vous en
penseriez c'est affligeant franchement
et
et si je peux me
permettre je suis très très soucieux de
la liberté de la presse et de votre
travail très respectueux de votre
travail mais vous allez avoir dans les
semaines qui viennent beaucoup de
sénatrices et de sénateurs y compris qui
vont venir vous dire régulariser c'est
faire un appel d'air pas une étude en
France et dans le monde confirme que
quand on régularise ça fait un appel
d'air c'est comme si on disait la terre
est plate quand ils vont vous dire la
France fait sa part comme a dit le
président de la République c'est faux
quand il dit la France fait plus que
tout le monde c'est faut nous faisons
moins que tout le monde donc c'est comme
si on disait la la chloroine Soanne la
covid et ils vont vous dire notre
système social est généreux ça nous
coûte cher et ben c'est comme si on
disait c'est Barbara stron qui a inventé
le dérèglement climatique s'il vous
plaît demandez-leur leur sources c'est
faux l'immigration c'est un
effet neutre ou sur les finances
publiques il y a jamais eu d'appel d'air
quand il y a la régularisation c'est
toutes les études toutes les études
françaises européenne de l'OCDE
américaine pas une étude ne confirme ces
délires on a dans notre pays une France
qui se lève tôt c'est celle qu'on a
applaudi pendant le covid c'est celle
qui ramasse les poubelles c'est celle
qui soigne c'est celle qui fait la
sécurité c'est celle qui fait les aides
à domicile régulariser cette France qui
se lève tôt c'est au-delà au
fond je dirais de l'efficacité
économique mais c'est simplement de
l'humanité vous rendez compte qu'ils
veulent supprimer l'aide médicale d'État
après le covid ils veulent qu'il y ait
des gens qui n'ai plus accès au soins
c'est délirant ils sont totalement
délirants raccrochés aujourd'hui à
l'extrême droite donc s'il vous plaît
quand ils vont venir vous dire mais
régulariser c'est l'appel d'air
dites-leur mais où quand comment
montrez-moi une étude qui justifie ça
c'est faux c'est juste faux et ça promet
des débats engagés dans l'émicycle ce
sera à partir du 6 novembre mercian
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
la une de la voie du Nord c'est la
broncholite oui et un traitement qui est
en tension tous les parents réussir
peut-être pas à la voir tout de suite et
c'est à lire ce matin dans la voie du
Nord merci Julien merci on passe au club
de territoire